Hello students in
Jonesboro and Westbury,
Dr. Ramos here again
and today we'll be
talking about neocortical
development. We don't
have time in the
curriculum to talk about
the development of all
the different parts
of the brain like the
cerebellum, thalamus,
or spinal cord, but
we're going to use
this one lecture to go
over one part of the
developing brain, the
neocortex that is,
to connect also with
our neuroembryology
lecture and just to give
a picture of how the
proliferation and
migration of cells come
together in the neocortex
to grow this part
of the brain, right?
The development of
the neocortex has been
studied in a little
bit more detail than
other parts of the brain,
so we have a better
understanding of the
molecular, genetic,
and cellular players,
and we understand how
neocortical malformations
arise. So this is
why this is the best
topic for one specific
lecture on the
development of a particular
part of the brain.
And I'll be walking
you through the major
steps in the development
of the neocortical
architecture that
we are already
pretty familiar with
from earlier lectures.
Here are the
session objectives
taken directly
from the CPG, so
I'm not going
to go over them.
I like to think about
brain development and
neocritical development
in terms of three
Ps. And we will go
over two of those Ps in
this lecture. The first
is neuronal production,
which relates to
the proliferation of
neurons, right, to
appropriately populate
the brain in general,
or in this case, to
appropriately populate
the cerebral cortex.
In many parts of the
body and many organ
systems, not only do
you have proliferation,
but then you have
cellular placement. So
that's the second P,
which is that process
where cells have to be
placed into particular
parts of that tissue
or organ, right? And
in the neocortex
placement has to do here
with the migration
of neurons into their
appropriate layer. So
you all remember that the
neocortex has a laminated
cytoarchitecture,
right? With horizontally
arranged neurons,
one on top of the
other. And then finally,
once you have the
right numbers of cells,
the first P, and
they're in the right
place, the second P,
now when it comes to the
brain, we know that
there is circuitry that
can be formed, the
synaptic connections,
which then allows for
the last P, which is
the performance of
that circuit or the
physiology of that circuit,
right? And together,
all these three P's
create the amazing
organ, the brain, that
controls our behavior.
All right, so as I
said, by now you're
all familiar with the
general architecture
of the cortex
with its sulci and
its gyri, its six
layers, several different
cell neuron types
and glial types.
Remember that the
majority of neurons in
the neocortex are
pyramidal cells that
have spiny dendrites,
have axons that make
local and long-range
connections with
other parts of cortex
and subcortical areas
as well right and
these pyramidal neurons
are glutamatergic
they have elaborate
dendrites with spines
so let's get started
with the first p which
is neuronal production
and obviously
what we're talking
about here is a dramatic
change in the size
and the convolutions
of the brain that you
can see here in this
pictorial representation
of the gross brain
changes that one
sees from p from 21
weeks to about 40 weeks
which is uh right around
the time of normal
birth and obviously
the brain is growing
remarkably in size
because of cellular
proliferation
proliferation right and the
neocortex is changing
from a smooth surface
a smooth surface like
you see over here to
a surface full of sulci
and gyri including
the development of
those neuronal layers
that we talk about and
it's interesting that
layering is a characteristic
feature of many
other tissues not
just the brain so it
seems like in the process
of of the brain growing
and evolving in in
mammals it adapted a
similar architecture
like you see in other
organs and tissues like
skin or or bone etc
all right we're
going to continue the
discussion from the
neuroembryology lecture,
which remember took you
through neuralation,
formation of the
neural tube closure. We
talked about the primary
vesicles that grew
and expanded into the
secondary vesicles.
And now we're moving
into focusing on the
telencephalon, right?
The telencephalon,
which is those two
vesicles that develop
into the lateral
ventricles and where we we
have progenitor cells
that will divide and
make the neurons of
the cerebral cortex.
So here we have
histology from
a 10-week-old
fetus where we can
see a large
lateral ventricle,
and right along the
lateral ventricles where
we have the progenitor
cells that will
divide to produce the
cortical neurons, right,
and if we zoom in into
this area here and
move over here to
the right-hand side,
we're looking at three
different weeks, three
different time periods
of that same region
as the neocortex is
beginning to develop.
All of this area in
white that you see down
here is going to be
the lateral ventricle.
Okay,
so at six weeks,
six and a half weeks
of gestation, we
pretty much only have
two layers. We have
the marginal zone up
here, right, which
becomes layer one,
and we have the neural
epithelial layer
shown here.
And now notice that
we have a group of
cells up here in the
marginal zone called the
Cajal Cajalretzius cells,
right? Cajalretzius
cells, Cajalretzius
cells over here.
We'll come back to
these cells, but
just remember that
they are in the
marginal zone, which
becomes layer one.
And now let's look
at how by at eight
weeks, we now have
this extra layer
of cells appearing
in what will be
what is called the
cortical plate,
right that we didn't
have that that layer
of cells at six and
a half weeks or seven
weeks so now we have
the cortical plate
well what's happened
here is that we had
neuronal proliferation
and migration from the
neural epithelial
areas right that are
now building the
neocortical architecture,
right? And the
cells that are
creating these
cells again are here
in the neural
epithelial layer.
All right, let's continue
growing the cortex
from eight weeks
to eight and a half
weeks of gestation.
Let's look at the size
of the cortical plate
here at eight weeks,
right? And look at
the size at eight and
a half weeks of
the cortical plate,
right? So this is
kind of almost doubled
in thickness. And
again, look at the
thickness of the entire
tissue in general,
right? Almost doubling
in size. And again,
what we have is we have
continued proliferation
from neural
epithelial cells down
here, and we have
migration of these neurons
radially in towards
the peel surface into
the cortical plate.
Remember that ultimately
we're going to end
up having our six
layers of neocortex,
like we see here, where
we're going to have
sulci and gyri, lobes,
and something
of note is that
layer one, which
we see over here,
is pretty much
always devoid of
lots of cells. So
here's all of layer
one over here.
If we zoom in,
Here is layer one,
right?
There are cells in layer
one, but they're
mostly glia.
And it's layer two
through six, two through
six here, that has the
majority of neurons.
And remember, the
cortical architecture
starts from layer
one at the most peel
surface and going down
to layer six all the
way till we get to the
white matter, okay?
So we have neurons
being produced over time
by neural epithelial
cells, and the cells
that are capable of
dividing and making
the neurons are called
radial glia, like we
see here, radial glia.
The radial glia are
located in divide at
the ventricular zone,
which is this area
right here, right along
the border of the
lateral ventricle. So
this is also the
ventricular zone over here.
right?
And as newborn
neurons are being
born and migrate
into cortical plate,
right? The cortical
plate is going
to keep getting
bigger and bigger.
Layer one is not
getting thicker
because those cells
don't migrate into
layer one, except
in some pathological
conditions that
we'll talk about.
And I should make
sure to mention
that there are lots
of different names
for this layer one
up here, marginal
zone, molecular
layer, layer one.
And again,
zooming into this
area, we see over
here there are
cells, but not a
lot of neurons.
Let's take a closer
look at those
radioglia. So
we're going to be
zooming in on this
red box, which is
this big picture
that we see here,
right?
And then if we zoom
into this little
red box, now we get
to see this picture
here. And I hope you
can see that if we
zoom, as we zoom in
further and further,
we're right here
at the ventricular
zone surface, we can
catch some of those
radioglial cells
that are dividing,
right? I hope you
can see that this
is the classic
shape of a dividing
cell in one stage of
mitosis here, right?
Now, if you label these
cells with more
sophisticated
techniques, so let's
say you express
a fluorescent
protein, what you
see is a cell that
looks like this,
okay? And this edge right
here is the
ventricular zone,
right? So this cell
has a radially oriented
shape, and it's got
a cell body, which we
see here, and it's got
one process, one fiber,
kind of like a dendrite,
but we call it a
radial fiber that
touches the peel surface
and another fiber
that touches the
edge of the ventricular
zone surface.
And that's how they got
their name, radioglia,
because of these
radial fibers. And what
we're going to do is
with this cell that's
labeled with our green
fluorescent protein,
we're going to use video
microscopy to track
this radial glial cell
over time. So this
red arrow represents
time. And we can look
at the cell's behavior.
And what you see is
that the radial glia
does a dance, a little
bit of a dance, but
will tend to dock right
at the ventricular zone
surface right here.
And it's at the
VZ where you
see this one
radial glial cell
divide and now become
two cells, right? Can
you see that? So now
we have one and two.
One and two.
We're tracking
this cell over time.
And now here it's very
obvious where we have
two cells,
okay? And this cartoon
over here does a
great job of illustrating
what I'm trying
to show which is
that we go from one
radioglial cell
labeled with r that
divides and now we
have the daughter cell
which is in dark
green okay so this is
the process of neuronal
proliferation which
is making the cells
the pyramidal cells
that then populate
the neocortex all
right so why is it
important to understand
neuronal proliferation
and particularly
proliferation for
the neocortical
development well it's
because there are disorders
of neuronal production
that result in
a condition known as
primary microcephaly.
Microcephaly is
defined as a small head
and small brain in
children under the
25th percentile or so,
for example. You can
see here the size of
the horizontal MRI
in the sagittal plane
and in the horizontal
plane of a normal
13-year-old female,
right, and
compare that to an
age-matched female
with microcephaly
caused by ASPM mutation,
right, on these
two left-hand
sides. So you
see a dramatic
reduction in skull
and brain size.
Surprisingly, the brain
architecture looks
pretty similar between
the two brains.
So all the different
brain nuclei are in
the right place, but
it's just a dramatic
reduction in brain
size because of the
deficit in neuronal
production of these
radioglial cells,
right? And the gene that
causes this microcephaly
in this patient is
ASPM, which stands
for abnormal spindle
pole mutant. And ASPM,
like we're seeing in
this staining over
here, is important for
mitotic profiles of
dividing cells at
different stages of
the cell cycle, right?
And just to show you
how important this
gene is across mammals,
you can see that
gene knockout of ASPM
and ferret, like you
see here, this is the
knockout for ASPM,
cause microcephaly
in the ferret
compared to the
normal brain,
right? So this gene
and its encoded
protein are
important in cell
division in radioglia
and is conserved
in primates,
carnivores, and mice.
And so
what we're talking
about here is that
ASPM is important for
our radioglial cells
down here that are
dividing along the
ventricular zone,
right? And if these
cells cannot divide
properly, then you're
going to end up with
a smaller population
of newborn neurons
and potentially
microcephaly.
Another great
example of primary
microcephaly comes
from individuals with a
mutation in a gene
called citron kinase.
So here are two
affected children,
here one and here two,
that have microcephaly
due to the mutation
in citron kinase.
and we also know
that citron kinase
mutation in rats causes
microcephaly. So look
at the small head
and these animals
also have a small brain
compared to a normal
animal of the same
age and citron
kinase knockout in
mice also causes
microcephaly. So here
is the citron kinase
knockout mouse compared
the size of the brain
to the normal animal
with functional
citron kinase.
All right, and
just like ASPM,
citron kinase plays
an important role
in cell division.
But instead of
being like ASPM being
in the spindles,
citron kinase is
localized and important
for cytokinesis. So
it's localized at the
cleavage furrow and
plays a role in those
final steps where the
two daughter cells
are going to disconnect
from each other,
right? And so the
consequence of that
failed cytokinesis in
humans and rats and
mice, like I said, these
mutations have been
found in humans,
rats, and mice. the
consequence is that
you have neurons with
multiple nuclei so I'm
showing you the three
zoomed in cells where
you can see multiple
nuclei from the
neocortex of a human
microcephaly patient
with mutation of
citron kinase and
over here I'm showing
images of rat binucleate
neurons, right,
from a rat that
also had mutation in
citron kinase. So again,
what we're talking
about here is
radioglial cells needing
all these different
molecular and
genetic players for
cell division. And if
anything goes wrong
in the physiology
or the mechanics of
cell division, be it
because of abnormal
spindles or because
the strong kinase at
the cleavage furrow,
you're going to end
up with fewer produced
neurons, which can
cause microcephaly.
Instead of microcephaly,
you can see the
opposite condition
known as megalencephaly,
where you have prolonged
proliferation of
radioglia, which is
going to cause an
overproduction of
neurons, right? So take a
look at the normal
MRI here that we see
compared to two patients
on the right that have
hemi-megalencephaly.
So one hemisphere,
this hemisphere here
in the coronal and in
the horizontal, this
one hemisphere here,
is enlarged and in
this patient this other
hemisphere here and
here is enlarged right
because of the again the
prolonged proliferation
of radioglial cells
you can also show
this experimentally
in in animal models by
again mutating the
molecular and genetic
environment of radial
glia to cause them to
proliferate abnormally
or for abnormal periods
of time or to inhibit
them from stopping
to proliferate. And
you can create a giant
megalencephalic
mouse brain like you
see here compared
to the normal brain,
right? And notice
how the normal mouse
brain is normally
flat, whereas when you
produce activating
mutations in proliferation
genes, you see that
now you actually get
sulci and gyri in the
mouse brain, which
is not normally the case.
So again, understanding
the biology of
radioglia and the
genes and molecules
that regulate their
proliferation help us
to understand conditions
like microcephaly
versus megalencephaly.
All right, so one more
time in summary of
this part, neuronal
production refers to
the proliferation of
neurons in order to
appropriately populate
the brain. Radioglial
cells are those
proliferative cells that
divide to make up neurons
at the ventricular
zone of the neural
epithelium, and too
much or too little of
neuronal production
leads to microcephaly
or megalencephaly.
And so now we're going
to switch gears from
proliferation to neuronal
placement and how
each subsequent round
of neurons being made,
how does that then
tie into the evolution
of the layers and the
formation of the layers,
better put. And again,
the six-layer side
or architecture of
the neocortex is the
defining organization of
this part of the brain
and what helps the
circuitry of all the
different functions that
the neocortex is able
to perform. So to
understand neuronal
placement we're going to
have to go back to our
little cartoon and
we're going to track our
radioglial cell again
which we saw earlier.
Let's look at this
expanded cartoon of
our radioglial cell
at the ventricular
zone. We also have
our marginal zone up
here, so the peel
surface up here, and
we have our developing
cortical plate,
right? And remember
that we have
our radioglial
cell here in
green. As we
mentioned earlier,
our radioglial cell
likes to dock at the
ventricular zone
surface. It will divide
and create a daughter
cell, shown here in
dark green. Notice
how the daughter cell
in dark green begins
to move away from the
ventricular zone,
right, and adopts this
particular shape that
we call the bipolar
shape, right, and
it's moving radially
and gets some help
from the radial fiber.
Then around this
other area known as
the subventricular
zone and intermediate
zone, so in this
region, right,
we're tracking
the daughter cell.
Notice how the daughter
cell changes shape
from bipolar to
multipolar. And instead
of migrating radially,
it will do a dynamic
dance here in the
intermediate zone. And
we'll talk about how
the intermediate zone
becomes the white
matter of the mature
neocortex. Okay. It's
not entirely certain
what sort of
information the daughter
cell is getting here
in the intermediate
zone. but this to
be appears to be a
characteristic where
the the daughter cell
changes its shape
and movement patterns
and then the daughter
cell might go uh
down might you know
even go a little further
down to the
ventricular zone but
eventually it will um
change its shape again
become radial in shape
and it will migrate
radially up to the
cortical plate. So
here's the cortical
plate here. Remember
the cortical plate
is what is going to
become the mature
six-layer cortex. So
I've labeled that
here, two, three, four,
five, six. And remember
layer one is up
here um in the marginal
zone right now let's
while this daughter
cell is migrating let's
look at what our
radial glial cell does
it divides once again
right and notice how
this second daughter
cell that is uh colored
in in in white right
will pretty much
engage in the same
journey and the same
morphological change
and dynamic movement as
its older sister
daughter cell did, right?
So if we think about
these two, the dark
green cell and the white
cell as sister cells,
right? From the same
radial glial cell, you
know, let's say mom
as the example, right?
So what we're seeing
in this cartoon is the
combination of
proliferation from the
radioglial cell in
multiple rounds of division
and the migration of
those daughter cells,
right, as they ultimately
end up into the
cortical plate. And let's
add one more element
to this, which is that
with each round of
proliferation, the
next wave of daughter
cells will migrate past
the earlier daughter
cells and migrate on
top of that earlier born
daughter cell to
produce an inside-out
pattern of lamination.
So what I mean is that
can you see here how
the first daughter cell
in dark green might
end up in, let's say,
layer five, right? And
what we see is that
the second daughter
cell here in white is
going to migrate just
a bit higher, just a
bit higher up to a, a
higher cortical layer.
Let me, let me, let
me go over that again
one more time with
a different cartoon
that might make it
a little bit more
clear. So we have our
radioglial cell that
divides and makes a
first daughter cell.
And we're going
to track the
radioglial cell
and the daughter
cell over time,
of course.
And notice how the
daughter cell, number
one, migrates into
the cortical plate,
right?
While it's migrating, the
radioglial cell
divides again,
we see here, and makes
a second daughter cell.
And, um, notice how
this, this second
round daughter cell
migrates past the earlier
one. So here we
have the first round
and now the second
round daughter cell.
And while daughter
cell number two is
migrating, our radial
glial cell divides again.
and this round of
daughter cells is going
to migrate on top
of both of those
earlier born and what
we see here is daughter
cell three ultimately
migrates above
one and two and and
uh shown here is also
that the fourth
round daughter cell
migrated above all of
them. So this is known,
again, as the inside
-out radial migration
to establish the
neocortical layers.
There are now
sophisticated techniques
to label the daughter
cells of radioglia
using retroviruses
and encoding
fluorescent proteins.
And here in this
picture, we have four
daughter cells that
were born from one
radioglial cell.
And what we can see is,
first of all, the
daughter cells are
in different layers,
right? So this
daughter cell is in
layer 6, layer 5, layer
4, layer 2, none
in layer 1, right?
And what we know is
that the daughter
cell in layer 6 was
the first one born.
The daughter cell
in layer 5 was the
second, and we have
the third and the
fourth. kind of
like what we see,
what we saw in our
cartoon over here.
Okay, so we have other
examples as well,
where we have
four daughter cells
in this picture,
and three daughter
cells in this
picture from the
same radial glial
cell. And we can see
how the subsequent
rounds of cell
division produce
neurons, daughter cells,
that migrate further
and further radially
and occupy more and
more superficial layers
of the neocortex.
Okay,
another interesting
feature to make note
of is how the
daughter cells are all
kind of lined up
radially in what looks
like a column,
right? You see that
here and you see that
consistently in all
the cartoons that
I've been showing.
And I'll show this
slide again just
to emphasize how
the daughter cell
will use the radial
fiber as a ladder or
as a rope to find its
way to the cortical
plate. So even though
it might might use
the radial fiber to
get out of the vz
area and then it will
use the radial fiber
again to make it into
the cortical plate
okay so this is how
you end up with the
columnar organization
of daughter cells
in the developing
neocortex and here in
this picture, I hope
you can see that you
can even notice columns
in this prenatal
section of a 37-week
-old cortex, right?
So in about
three more weeks,
this child would be born.
Here's layer one
up here, right? And
here are the other
layers. And I hope you
can see the radial
columns that are
present throughout the
cortical thickness.
The radial columns are
a lot more difficult
to identify in the
adult brain since the
cortex has expanded
quite a bit and the
neurons have spread
out, and now you have
dendrites and axons
that have been growing.
And again, related
to the inside-out
radial migration,
we know that the
earliest-born cells
down here, right,
are in the deep
layers and the latest
born cells are up
here in layer two.
So the young neurons
are at the top and
the older neurons
are at the bottom
according to their
their birth date, right?
All right, so let's
kind of take a step
back and look at the
big picture of cortical
development and the
establishment of
sulci and gyri. There's
a lot more prenatal
MRI that's being
performed. So there's
a lot of data out
there about changes in
size and shape and
the developing cortex.
You can see that about
at around 18 weeks,
the cortical plate
is pretty thick,
right? But the brain
is still pretty smooth
and there's not a lot
of sulci and gyri.
One of the first major
convolutions that
you see is the
sylvian fissure here.
And then of
course there's the
interhemispheric fissure
at the midline, right?
At about 26 weeks, we
can see a couple of
little bumps here.
These are going to be
the beginning of the
central sulcus, precentral
gyrus, and postcentral
gyrus, right?
And then at 30 weeks,
you can see those
bumps are a little
bit more mature here,
right?
So you don't have to
memorize the timing of
these features, but
what's important is
that those biggest
characteristic sulci and
gyri that we teach in
neuroanatomy lab are
the ones that are
developing first, right?
And here at 30 weeks,
we also have the
cingulate gyrus,
and here we have the
calcarine fissure of
the occipital lobe,
right? So again, you
don't need to memorize
this, but what you
can see is that
these major landmarks
are being formed as
the neocortex is
getting thicker, right?
Thicker and thicker,
and this is going
to cause the cortex
to begin to fold
upon itself to form
those sulci and gyri.
Here is data from
a study where
they tried to make
a kind of average
time course of
the folding and
the formation of
sulci and gyri.
And in these
images, we have
frontal lobe over
here, and we have
occipital lobe
back here, right?
So beginning at
about 26 weeks,
you're really only seeing
the central sulcus,
right? You're seeing
the sylvian fissure,
and you would
also see the
interhemispheric fissure,
which we can't see.
And then you see the
characteristics sulci
and gyri appearing at
these average times.
And then at closest
to birth, for example,
35 weeks shown in
this study, you can
see there's still a
lot of sulci and gyri
left to be formed in
the frontal lobes,
right? And there's
really good evidence that
the frontal lobes
are among the latest
parts of the neocortex
to be developed,
right? And again, like
we saw before, central
sulcus, one of the
earliest characteristic
features of the
developing neocortex.
all right so just
like it's important to
understand proliferation
and cortical
development it's also
important to understand
neuronal migration in
cortical development
because there are a
broad range of neural
placement disorders
so disorders of uh
neuronal migration where
the neocortex does not
form properly okay
these are not again
proliferation disorders
like microcephaly or
hemimegalencephaly.
Instead, these are
migration disorders that
disrupt the organization
of the neocortex,
and we're going to
talk about several
flavors of them, okay,
and build on what
we already know from
our discussion about
radioglia and the
migration of the
daughter cells, right?
So there's one type
of neuronal placement
disorder where you
see nodules, you
see heterotopic nodules
in the ventricles.
So here we have
a gross specimen
and we see the lateral
ventricle right here.
And I hope you can
see these nodules
that are lining the
ventricular wall.
and even in
this MRI, I hope
you can see all
these nodules,
right, which
are heterotopic
collections of neurons,
right? So all
these neurons in
here belong in
the neocortex,
but they have not
migrated properly,
right? So periventricular
nodular heterotopia,
like we're seeing
here, is an example
of where newborn
neurons, newborn daughter
cells, fail to leave
the ventricular
zone and end up
forming these nodules.
For all of these
kinds of malformations
that we'll talk about,
there is a growing
list of genes that have
now been identified
for these migration
disorders, right?
And now that whole
genome sequencing is
more readily accessible,
we're beginning to
learn a lot more about
the genetic mechanisms
that cause these
disorders. So one of
the mutations that cause
causes periventricular
nodular heterotopia
is filament A,
okay, which is an
actin binding protein.
And these proteins
are likely involved
in, you know, movement
and shape change
related activities
inside the cell during
migration, right? And
mutations in filament
A cause periventricular
heterotopia
in humans as well as
mice, right? So mice
can have periventricular
heterotopia as
well. So here's an
example over here of
the normal architecture
of the cortex in
a mouse, right? And
notice how, and here
is the lateral
ventricle in the mouse.
But we can see in a mouse
with mutation
of filament A,
we see these
nodules right along
the ventricle.
And if we zoom
in, we can see
that these are
cortical neurons.
And again, in these
mouse studies, if you
use a marker of
cortical neurons in the
control mouse the
normal mouse you see
all the cortical neurons
up here in the in
the cortical plate
but in the filament
a knockout I hope you
can see that you see
some of those cortical
neurons labeled
as well as down here
stuck near the lateral
ventricle where where
they don't belong
right so this is again
not a proliferation
problem this is a
migration problem
and what we're talking
about is again how
our radial glial
cell will divide and
make a daughter cell
and instead of leaving
the ventricular
zone it gets stuck.
Stuck here with many
other rounds of daughter
cells forming nodules
and importantly
this kind of malformation
is associated
with cognitive
disability and epilepsy.
Let's move to another
neuronal migration
disorder called subcortical
band heterotopia,
also known as double
cortex syndrome.
So in this condition,
instead of seeing
nodules in the
ventricles, what we see is
a band of gray matter
that's trapped in
what would normally
be the white matter.
Okay, so I'm trying
to outline here that
extra band of gray
matter that you see.
Okay, so this is why
it's called double
cortex because we have
this extra, you know,
area of gray matter,
right? So we have
white matter in these
dots that I'm drawing,
gray matter another
band of white matter
and then gray matter
right if we look at
the histology of the
of the let's look
first look at the normal
cortex we see with
a cell body stain
we can see the gray
matter up here and
then we see the white
matter here right but
notice in our affected
patient with subcortical
band heterotopia,
we see gray matter
up here, we see a
little bit of white
matter, then we have
another collection of
gray matter, and then
more white matter
here. This is where the
term double cortex
syndrome comes from.
Okay, so the cells
have migrated away from
the ventricular zone
surface, right? So this
is not like
periventricular nodular
heterotopia. Instead,
they've migrated a little
further away, but now
are stuck, right? And
these cells otherwise
should have migrated
all the way up to the
cortical plate, right?
Patients with mutations
in EML1, DCX, or
LIS1 will exhibit
subcortical band heterotopia.
Note that all these
genes are microtubule
-associated genes,
encoding for microtubule
-associated proteins,
right? And I think
you've learned a little
bit about microtubules
and the importance
of these proteins in
cytoskeletal shape
and the features of
cells, especially neurons
that have elaborate
shape, right?
And so again, based
on our cartoon, if we
use our cartoon as a tool
to help us understand
neuronal migration,
what we think is
happening here, we
have our radial glial
cell that is able to
divide, right? And that
daughter cell is able
to leave the ventricular
zone area, right?
This is why we don't
get the periventricular
nodules, right?
But something goes
wrong when the daughter
cell is in the SVZ
and the intermediate
zone, the intermediate
zone and subventricular
zone. I mentioned a
while back that these
areas are what
become the developing
cortical white matter.
So something must go
wrong, such as deficient
EMX1 or DCX or LIS1
or microtubule function
so that these cells
can change their shape,
become radial again,
and then migrate up
to the cortical plate,
right? So again, they
get stuck in here,
right, which results
in them being here.
So, you know, the
microtubules or
cytoskeletal proteins
are not working
properly to allow
these cells to
migrate out of the
intermediate zone.
And again, like we saw
with periventricular
nodular heterotopia,
patients affected
with double cortex
syndrome are going to
have cognitive
disabilities and epilepsy.
We have talked about
conditions where the
neurons don't migrate
enough and get
stuck in the near the
ventricle or the white
matter. Now let's look
at another condition
where the neurons
migrate too far and
and don't end up in
their appropriate
layer. So remember
that the normal cortex
we have our six layers
and layer one up
here doesn't have a
lot of neurons, right?
Instead it has a lot
of glia and axons.
I want you to take
a look at something
that's called
molecular layer
heterotopia or layer
one heterotopia here
in these two images
from human brains.
Sometimes they're also
called marginal zone
heterotopia and basically
what these are are
collections of hundreds
or thousands of
neurons that have migrated
too far into layer
one. Notice how on either
side of these areas,
shown here or here,
layer one is pretty
clean, very few cells,
right? But in this
focal area, we have
neurons that have migrated
too far. And this is
something that you see
in patients with epilepsy
and patients with
dyslexia, particularly
in regions like
temporal lobe and frontal
lobe areas. So this
might tie to the speech
and language processing
that you see in some
of these patients.
And again, going back
to our cartoon to
describe what we think
is happening with these
malformations is
that the neurons, so
you have your radial
glial cell, it
divides, the daughter
cell is able to
leave the ventricular
zone, right, is
labeled to leave the
intermediate zone.
And it continues
on its journey
and begins to
migrate into the
cortical plate.
And instead of
stopping at its
appropriate layer, right,
the cell migrates
too far into
layer one, like
you see here.
Okay, so not a lot of
information is known
about the, you know,
what causes these,
this kind of
heterotopia, but
there is a lot
of work doing,
being done in
animal models.
Let me show you a
little bit of data from
work in animal models
of molecular layer
heterotopia that I think
can still teach us a lot
about what these
malformations in humans.
So over here, we
have an example of
staining for a molecule
that's only found
in layer four neurons
called ROAR-B,
right? Can you see
how the staining is
mostly restricted
to this band here?
All of this would
be layer four
in the mouse. I
hope you can see
how there are a lot of
cells in this little
malformation here
that also express ROR
B, right? So this is
evidence that neurons
that belong in layer
layer four that express
ROR B have migrated
too far, right? They
migrated too far and
now they're in layer
one where they don't
belong. And there's
another example I'll
show here with staining
for a molecule called
CTGF, right? And CTGF
is only found in
layer six cortical
neurons, but I hope you
can see here that in
that molecular layer
heterotopia, you have
some neurons that are
expressing this gene.
And this is evidence
that these cells up
here in the malformation
belong long in layer
six, but have migrated
too far. Okay. And
so we think that this
is likely also true of
these heterotopia in
humans, which is that
they're a collection
of neurons from all
different layers that
are in layer one, forming
this abnormal, abnormal
circuit that might
contribute to some
of the functional
deficits that you see
in people with epilepsy
or dyslexia, where
these malformations have
been found, right? And
hopefully someday soon
we'll see some anatomical
studies in humans
where we'll be able
to confirm that this
type of anatomical
change is also present.
All right. And the
last type of neuronal
migration disorder
that I want to
talk about that's
very global, a big,
pretty huge deficit
It is called
lisencephaly that
maybe you've been
exposed to before in
a previous lecture.
Lisencephaly
is a generic,
lisencephaly means
smooth brain and
it's basically a
generic term where
you have a reduction
or complete loss
of the sulcine gyri
of the neocortex.
So there's a continuation
of lisencephaly.
There is agyria,
which means no
gyri, or pachygyria,
which is characterized
by few or large
and broad gyri, so
a kind of incomplete
lisencephaly. So
here is an example
of pachygyria,
right, with large,
broad sulci and gyri.
And you can see in
these other examples how
smooth the cortical
surface looks compared
to the normal brain
full of sulky and
gyri, right? There
are lots of genes that
cause lisencephaly and
that list is growing.
One of the genes
involved in lisencephaly
is called, where's
my cursor, is relin,
although So only 1% of
patients with realin
mutations have
listencephaly. I wanted to
mention it because it's
one of the genes whose
function during
cortical development is
beginning to be more
and more understood.
So it turns out that
realin is expressed
and released by
the Cajal-Retzia
cells that we
talked about a long
time ago at the very
beginning of this
lecture when we
were looking at the
developing neocortex
in the human, right?
So remember that we
have these Cajal-Retzia
cells in the marginal
zone or layer one,
right? They're not in
the neural epithelial
zone and they're
above the
cortical plate,
right? Right?
So, the Cajal-Retzi
cells are a unique
type of cell in the
developing cortex.
They're not born from
radial glia. They're
born in a separate
part of the developing
brain and they migrate
up to layer one.
So again, up here,
we have our marginal
zone and we have
our cortical plate.
And notice how we
have our inside-out
pattern of neuronal
migration. So
cell division round
1, 2, 3, 4 are
being stacked upon
each other, right?
And what we know,
like I was mentioning,
is that our Cajal
-Retzia cells express
and release Relin.
And And they think
that Relin is a
molecular cue that helps
to keep the neuronal
migration nice and
tidy, right? And in
this cartoon here,
what's being drawn is
how the Cajal Ritzia
cell no longer expresses
is realin, right?
And now how our
daughter cells are all
jumbled in the
wrong layers, spread
throughout the different
cortical lamina,
right? And so what you
see in this encephaly
is not only do you
see a loss of sulci
and gyri, but when you
look at the histology,
you see a kind
of a loss loss of
lamination and a smearing
of cortical neurons
throughout the different
cortical layers.
Right?
So again, if you
have mutations in
realin, you're disrupting
that signaling,
the neurons are not
migrating to the right
place. And so the
cortex is not growing
properly to fold properly,
like you would see.
So there is some really
nice animal studies
looking at realin
mutations. And I'll show
you first in the
normal mouse, using
different markers for
different layers and
using different colors,
you can see how the
cortical layers have
cell types organized
horizontally, right?
And each color is a
different gene that's
expressed by the different
cell types. And you
see there's nice
orderly layers. But in
a mouse with mutation
of relin, I hope you
can appreciate how
there's basically
dislamination and all the
different neurons are
spread throughout the
cortex. So lamination
is basically lost.
And again, just
like in the human,
when you have
mutations of relin, for
example, here there's
a strain of sheep.
I forget where these
sheep are found. I think
in South America that
have a spontaneous
mutation of relin,
what you see is that
compared to the normal
sheep brain that has a
nice, you know, sulci
and gyri, the mutant
sheep that express
relin have a form of
lysencephaly, right? So
you can see that here
in the coronal sections
where we have the
normal sheep with all
its sulci and gyri
versus the relin mutant
sheep that basically
has lisencephaly. So
again, I mentioned these
aspects so that we
can try to understand
how the human phenotype,
the human brain
malformation that we
observe, is created
at the molecular
and cellular level.
So this takes us
to the end of our
lecture. I want to
remind all of you about
our radial glia and
how they give rise
to the newborn
neurons that migrate
in an inside-out
pattern of migration
to help form the six
layers of the neocortex.
The radial fibers
contact the peel surface
and and form a substrate
kind of like a ladder
or a rope for neurons
to migrate but
they're also important
molecular cues in the
developing neocortex
like relin from the Cajal
Ritzia cells And,
of course, there are
intracellular machinery,
intracellular proteins
like those microtubule
proteins that, when
perturbed, can cause
heterotopia where
neurons don't migrate
enough. right um so all
in all um whenever
neuron whenever neuronal
placement is altered
you're going to have
deficits in lamination
just like when
neuronal production is
altered you're going
to have deficits in
in brain size right
And so please reach
out if you have
any questions and
feedback is welcome.